[Music]
okay my name is Marissa John and I'm
gonna tell you about the nanny van which
is a mobile design studio and sound lab
that accelerates the movement for
domestic workers rights and we are
working with domestic workers nationwide
our key partners National Domestic
Workers Alliance and we are creating new
resources to improve their welfare
so to understand where we're coming from
you first need to know that in the 1930s
and 40s the New Deal labor laws
intentionally excluded domestic workers
from receiving those same rights however
in New York and 2010 domestic workers
won a bill of rights that guarantees
minimum and overtime wage and so forth
and now what's really exciting is that
those laws are changing nationwide so
but in New York to inform the 200,000
domestic workers about their newfound
rights we created this tool where you
can call in using any kind of phone and
hear humorous episodes about the law or
about health and safety this is the logo
that we produced on the business cards
and the Flyers and the way that the word
gets out is primarily through advocacy
groups and a lot of on-the-ground
outreach by nannies to each other in the
park and a key thing to know is that you
can access it using any kind of phone so
even a really basic GP phone so now as I
mentioned the laws are changing
nationwide and Massachusetts is going to
be the fourth state to pass their Bill
of Rights and so we're creating a
national version of that and to do that
we created the nanny van so essentially
we've been trekking around the country
and meeting with domestic workers so we
have a couple different groups that we
think of as a demographic okay so we
have the domestic workers and we have
done a lot of surveys and then
evaluative feedbacks and we know that we
reach them primarily through basic GP
cell phones then we also work with
domestic employers and we they have
indicated that their most
keen to access stuff via the web and
then for the general public or what we
think of as left-leaning liberals who
are inclined to want to do the right
thing it's via social media so in
Twitter specifically to an our Facebook
so here are some of the examples of
events and ways of outreach here's a
group of nannies at the SF Public
Library doing a lion dance to the tunes
the Nanta here is a group of 140 and
nannies not all in the picture here and
they are creating nanny van Grahams
dedicated to political leaders and the
pictures are then tweeted to local
leaders and then delivered in person so
in Massachusetts they were delivered to
the Statehouse and that's for the other
demographic the fourth demographic is
political leaders and that's in-person
meetings as well as those tweets so
we've been really kind of crafting and
honing the specific ways that we reach
these very different demographics
employers outreach includes things like
farmers markets or food truck stops or
here we are at a private high school
doing workshops with high schoolers -
who likely have domestic workers here we
are creating placemats for the children
of domestic employers an idea is that
people color it in the kids color again
it goes on to the refrigerator it's a
kind of trickle up tip so this is what
our audience engagement plan looks like
and we've been crafting and haunting and
so forth so the thing that really blew
us away through all of this was that a
few weekends ago we went to the Queens
Museum where we had an event and it was
really successful you're got a couple of
hundred on nanny van Grahams created
mostly domestic employers as well as the
general public so culture and going
left-leaning public and then that was on
a Saturday and then the Sunday what
happened was there was this antique Auto
Show and so we backed at The Nanny van
there it is in the background and we
backed it about 20 feet and then all of
a sudden there was thousands people
coming by to take all of our resources
and this was just so this is like we had
not anticipated antique a car fit
as part of a demographic and so here is
dom art ali who runs the auto antique
show in the queens and it's this kind of
roving thing and that really exploded
what we think of as the general public
and so now as we're continuing to go
across the country here we are at Grand
Canyon
we're just rethinking this idea of
general public and opening our minds as
to who who is interested in domestic
workers rights and these new ways to
support domestic employers and workers
and that's been the most interesting
thing for me thank you